Gus Ramsey who texted me a great story
during the commercial break on my Gus
you got a call in how are you Gus I'm
great rich are you buddy did you hear DP
and I go down memory lane there huh yeah
that was great that was great and that's
one of the great things about stielike I
have a friend who says you know in a lot
of ways your legacy is just the stories
that people tell about you after you're
done and students got a lot of legacies
but on the short list of the top of his
legacy is the stories that we get to
tell about us and so which one you test
to go for it you've got the flood good
because you knew his stew when he was a
broadcaster locally in Orlando before he
even got to ESPN yeah I was working at
the NBC affiliate in Orlando with hopes
of becoming a sportscaster and was
working on my face and all that and they
decided to hire still out of Raleigh as
a news reporter so he came to our
station hated them because he stole my
job but we became fast friends and it
was pretty clear from day one that he
was a competitive person and we
organized kind of like a touch football
game for people at the station to play
and he and I are on opposite team and so
in my best
Edna Catholic moment I read all playing
across the meadow Laurie catch the pass
and I turns around on field and there's
two already down like low knees bent
with like the Jack Tatum towel hanging
from the back of the swords and he's got
the goggles on and the Carolina blue
shorts or whatever and I'm thinking oh
god he's having a flashback he's on the
field now he's gonna take me out and for
whatever reason in my life I guess
because I used to be a good jumper my
defense mechanism is to jump when I'm in
danger so as I'm running towards him and
his eyes are getting bigger and bigger I
just think I'm gonna hurt all over him
of course dude then raises up as I jump
and he totally upended me and I slipped
and I come down and I land on my head
but I get a head pointer and I'm
crutches for like four days but there's
no other person I know that I would have
been scared of running at playing touch
football game
father events to because I knew of his
competitive nature and where his brain
was he you know he's one of those guys
he's in the moment he's not playing
touch football he's now the defensive
back you is supposed to be at the
University of North Carolina
I was going to do from the Wolfpack who
came over the middle how dare I went
over the middle against he and when he
tried out for the Jets he literally
thought is gonna make the Jets and I
said to him like what are you talking
about you're just doing a piece sort of
you know like a paper lion right like to
try and join a team and see if you can
make it and you won't but he swore to me
he was gonna make the Jets spoiler alert
he didn't but that's exactly who he was
and he looked at me goes you've got to
speak it into existence rich you've got
to believe it that's why Allen Iverson
is the way he is
that's why Vince Carter is away he is
and I literally was going to stop and
say so are you comparing yourself to
those guys he absolutely was oh yeah you
know it wasn't I guess for the nature of
the injury let's say the ball had him in
the shoulder and located the shoulder he
would have been super proud of that you
know but because it was the I use a
little more sense of it but when we were
living in Orlando
I called him said hey you want to go
pick up play some pickup hoops yes sir
coming over and get me so I go into an
apartment I knock on the door and I just
hear him crying from inside come in come
in come in so I come into the apartment
he's lying on the floor grabbing his
ankle he's imagining it so what the hell
happened he said I jumped over this pile
of laundry and I landed wrong he's
telling people there's a fire story
right it was always about what's the
best story I tell gussy man I can't
believe he's gone five years and it's
great to see what his beautiful
daughters are doing on his behalf and
and you know I know you know them - I've
got about a minute left if you want to
say anything one more thing about
Stewart his kids or his foundation and
they're they're wonderful people you can
go on Twitter and you can see all the
different places you can donate today
sort and I have a dear friend the
collector here in Orlando Wendy Tod who
clock dancer for 18 years see this
this past month and she and Steve were
great friends they were very symbiotic
and their ability to put up a brave face
during the fight so god bless them god
bless anybody out there who's having to
deal with this the more that we can
pitch in together the more that we can
help other people the more like it feels
like Sue and Wendy will live on see
that's why you the program director of
dan Patrick school of broadcasting I
gave you about a minute you didn't even
have a stopwatch you hit it right on the
head Gus well done
take care take care gussy here you got
its guest Ramsey longtime ESPN producer
and Stuart Scott friend for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app